we know is the ozo the most exciting
thing you've ever worked on definitely
yes I was telling my boss and my family
that I really feel this to be a special
project it's one of those situations
where you have a great product but at
the right time where the market is ready
to receive it and understand exactly how
you're innovating in a specific space
fantastic why do you feel it's the right
time why 2015 or 2016 well the right
time actually was not really driven by
us but his external factors facebook
bought okaloosa there was no plan that
that was happening and suddenly the
whole industry is turning towards we are
like the big thing the past six eight
months you see so many companies
investing significant money in the VR
space and creating this great momentum
we've been so lucky because we started
two years ago not knowing that this was
going to happen this way but delivering
the product at the right time now you're
ahead of presents capture it was all
right okay in based in the bay area
right base in sunnyvale yes okay and
what exactly does your department do in
terms of making this beautiful piece of
machinery right here so presents capture
and the name of it is really focusing on
their reality part of virtual reality so
of course you have a lot of world
generated by computers that can take you
anywhere in fantasy world but we're
looking at the reality aspect so what we
focus on is to create devices that could
be in a capture area or in other areas
of the ecosystem in order to recreate
reality so that you can be either
teletransported or even travel in time
only towards the past not to the future
but you can go back and revisit
situation that you were part of but look
around and look in different direction
than the one that you choose when you
were there
november 30 2015 we're here in los
angeles at LA live what is tonight's
launch about what are we doing this
launch is really the beginning of a
journey we want to be inspirational in
this industry we believe the art will be
big and impactful for everybody I don't
think that people will look at picture
as they're looking at till today meaning
they're just rectangles pictures are
always 16 by 9 4 by 3 just rectangles
and now their spheres not only you can
go left and right but you can be fully
murs audio and video and this will be
just a new jersey new jersey and your
journey and inspirational because you
can inspire new ways of telling the
story giving inspire new businesses can
inspire new situation of consuming
entertainment that we never thought
about it snow here the first company to
launch a VR filmmaking camera we
definitely are not the first one in
terms of VR cameras are there are many
solution in the marketplace but we're
definitely a first one introducing a
professional dedicated device for VR
this this camera has been really
designed and invented from a blank sheet
of paper thinking about the best
solution and not creating a solution
with existing parts or components or
cameras that you know combined or duct
tape together in order to serve the need
but was designing completely thinking
about 360 video and 360 audio so those
are the components that make they also
unique I think that the uniqueness are
not only the technical solutions but
it's also the combination of the
technical solution and the design as you
can see it's very compact is
fundamentally recreating the size of a
head but it has eyes ears of course a
brain
and I think that the whole combination
of technical solution and design with no
compromise is is really fantastic now
the ozo is beautifully displayed to your
left there is that one phase of it will
there be other models of the ozo or for
now we're just sticking with this which
is strictly professional right well of
course we just started journey so we
want everybody to enjoy ozo use also
bios oh and but definitely just the
first step is the first step towards a
more solution for many problems we're
solving some problems very critical ones
by far we're not solving all the
problems and so that means that will be
a second and a thorough so and also
there will be a direction toward a
prosumer and eventually consumer because
we really believe that vr will expand
towards all the different market
segments and where do you see a virtual
reality filmmaking in the next five to
ten years I think is just a new land we
just discovered this new land and we're
going to walk around this new land and
people will invent so many new things I
think about when when people went from
pictures to movies it took I think three
or four years before they start walking
around with the camera because they
thought oh the camera can you know just
film everything in a static way and so
for VR storytelling and techniques to
entertain people with VR we're just at
the very very beginning and I don't know
what what people would invent but it's
clear that there is so much to be
discovered
do you envision moviegoers wearing the
headset is that I mean forgive me for my
lack of knowledge I know you mentioned
the oculus rift but and I know it's one
type of headset that's right uh do you
is that how one would view these movies
or or or i think i think that the
definition of movies is really will stay
stick with whatever is the movie today a
movie means a cinema or theatre cool
experience or on TV is a certain
experience it's like on radio you know a
radio program is different than a TV
program as different editing different
pace and so on so what we call video VR
or VR experiences I don't think that
will be the evolution of movies will be
another media another way of enjoying
the story there are great plays and you
go to the theater to see a play are you
comparing that with a movie of course
you can make a movie out of the play and
would be different is a different
product why because the expectation of
how to tell the story and the elements
that we're going to use to tell the
story are different a scrip of a play is
different from its grip of a movie and
will be different for VR experiences one
aspect that is really different is that
VR is compelling for multiple times of
viewing the same VR experience a movie
even a great movie we watch it twice
three times before in love with a movie
maybe four times but after that we tell
people you don't watch that movie is
fantastic for VR experiences every time
you can look in a different direction
and it's different you're not playing
the same thing is the same environment
but it's a different experience that
will really open a plethora of
opportunities we don't know I don't know
if you're able to talk about the price I
understand is $50,000 for the camera is
that something that you or the price
will be announced tonight so yes we can
we can talk about it
okay that's i knows availability soon
first of all you can pre-order oh so
starting from today so you can go on our
website or through the authorized
resellers and kick you can pre-order
also the price is going to be sixty
thousand dollars 60 of course the camera
comes with a kit of parts and
accessories in a beautiful case and the
availability of the product will be in
q1 2016 okay great so in the next few
months will it come already assembled or
or will solely okay is a professional
camera of course come a fully assemble
with some cables a very important
software to manage the camera and also
to preview in in real time what the
camera is seeing there's a fantastic
part of the product everything is
included in the in the sixty thousand
dollar thinking about some of the films
that you've loved over the years what
movies you wish had been filmed using
the arm there are so many definitely one
of my favorite was memento just because
it plays with memory and going back and
forward and I see really a strong value
for memories and going back in time and
being able to look in different
directions think about if you picture a
moment that you had with your
grandfather or someone in your family
when you were very young and you can go
back and instead of seeing just that
person that of course was in front of
you you can now turn around and see what
the others were doing over their faces
when you were engaging with a with this
relative at that at that time would be
fantastic
what are some of the features that
filmmakers and storytellers will really
love about those though we we already
saw that the pre-life previewing so
being able to sit inside although almost
like physically being squeezed inside
the sphere and see everything around it
and hearing everything around it is a
huge gain of course they're used to sit
behind a camera but behind the camera
there is a lot of stuff happening that
nobody sees and now they need to be
aware of everything around the camera
and they really love this feature that
allow them to live looking around before
shooting and organizing the actor Sir
the lights the scene itself is really
fantastic what is the technology that
enables the VR camera to work the saws
oh I mean it for a layman if you were no
elevator pee I would say we go back to
the basic it's really miniaturization
and fitting a lot of technology in a
very small space in a very efficient way
and also controlling heat when you put a
lot of technology in a small package
like your phone it gets warm sometimes
even hot because there is a lot of stuff
happening in a very small space and so
the the fundamental of these designer
and invention is that we were able to
squeeze a lot of sensors eight sensors
that were globally synchronized so
they're taking eight pictures all
together and sending this picture out in
one que bola all at the same time that
was really the invention
did you do any testing with with
professional GPS and what was their
reaction to it I know you have a great
video already online with pacemakers
about their experience yeah what we did
actually we did in two phases in a very
early stage at the beginning of this
year we want to validate the market is
the product we're working on something
that is interesting in the industry in
general right and are we doing it the
right way and that was fantastic because
the feedback was really consistent
positive and consistent although we also
know that we're addressing many critical
problems but not all of the problems and
then a second phase when we start having
the pre-production unit so the early
prototypes we of course went out and
start produced videos that were in the
mind of some of the key creators in the
VR industry and again that validation
was a really fun process not so much for
the engineers because as you can imagine
you know prototype sometimes fails and
now everything is working perfect but
was really fantastic because we were
able to collect the feedback from those
experts and also change a little bit
some of the choices that we made
initially based on those experiences who
are you making the product for we're
definitely making the product of for
what we call also believers or VR
believers that means of course at the
creative community telling the story in
a different way with a new tool but also
the business community there are new
businesses that can be enabled by also
think about if you have the best seat at
the show and thousands of people can
share it everywhere in the world like
being right there or maybe is just for
selling a big mansion from overseas or
visiting a place that doesn't exist
anymore all of those for Gary v's web
show Gary Vaynerchuk he talked about
advertising could also be huge service
absolutely you know some some of the
lines in the early stage of movies was
movies will take you to places
right now you can imagine this is really
taking you to places because you'll be
there and of course advertisement really
create an experience and as much as you
can involve emotions in that visual
experience your advertisement will be
more successful think about if you have
a video of someone that you really want
to meet close to you and then your star
or your fans of someone and they're
right there and they're talking to you
with this eye contact that make you
feeling like special as soon as you feel
special when I is the product that you
are advertising you would go for it